Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Did you know that our Sunday Times bestselling book, The Rest is History Returns, is now out in paperback. From finding out who British history's biggest lad was, to tracing the admittedly hazy ancient origins of Raiders of the Lost Ark, it's filled cover to cover with more curious historical moments than you can crack a lasso at.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你知道吗？我们荣登《星期日泰晤士报》畅销榜的书籍《历史的其余部分：回归》（The Rest is History Returns）现在已经推出平装版了。从探究谁是英国历史上最厉害的大男孩，到追溯《夺宝奇兵》中那些公认扑朔迷离的远古起源，这本书从头到尾都充满了比你挥舞套索还要多的奇妙历史瞬间。
Plus puzzles and a pub quiz, The Rest Is History Return, available now in all good bookshops. My reality, he says, is I wake up and go, I haven't done the Hannibal trilogy. He first started talking about this 18 years ago. His desire to make a trilogy about Hannibal Barca, the Carthaginian general, one of the greatest wartime generals in history, the man who in 218 BC led a troop of elephants over the Alps to invade Italy. I promised myself I would try to make the Hannibal trilogy. Part of creating mythology in Riddick and creating worlds like FAST in some bizarre way
此外还有各种谜题和酒吧问答，《历史的其余部分：回归》现已在各大优质书店上架。他说道：“我的现实就是，我醒来后会想，我还没拍《汉尼拔》三部曲呢。”他第一次谈到这个话题是在18岁的时候。他渴望拍摄一部关于迦太基将军汉尼拔·巴卡的三部曲——汉尼拔是历史上最伟大的战时将军之一，也是公元前218年率领一支大象部队翻越阿尔卑斯山入侵意大利的人。我向自己保证，我会尝试拍摄《汉尼拔》三部曲。在《星际传奇》中打造神话以及像《速度与激情》那样构建世界，从某种诡异的角度来看，
was preparation for the ultimate task. He will do it, he says. So that's a profile of the actor Vin Diesel, one of your favorite actors, Tom, in Men's Health in 2021. So in that article, Vin Diesel is talking about his great ambition to do a trilogy about the life of Hannibal, the Carthaginian general, and four years on, Diesel has not yet delivered. No, he hasn't.
其实都是为终极任务做准备。他会做到的，他是这么说的。这是《男子健康》杂志2021年对演员范·迪塞尔的一篇人物专访，范·迪塞尔也是你最喜欢的演员之一，汤姆。在那篇文章中，范·迪塞尔谈到了他拍摄一部关于迦太基将军汉尼拔生平的三部曲的宏伟抱负，然而四年过去了，迪塞尔还没有兑现承诺。不，他还没兑现。
We're still waiting for that Hannibal masterpiece. And why on earth, Tom, when it's such an amazing story, hasn't he done it? Because it's a story that would involve him taking an army, including 37 elephants, over the Alps, winning three of the most celebrated battles of all time, slaughtering enormous numbers of Romans and bringing Rome almost to her knees. And it is so epic that I imagine the costs would be prohibitive. And actually, the person who put me on to Vin Diesel's enthusiasm for Hannibal, Marina Hyde, as I rest his entertainment, very wittily commented on this, that to
我们还在等待那部汉尼拔的杰作。汤姆，既然这是一个如此惊人的故事，他为什么迟迟不拍呢？因为这个故事需要他带着一支包括37头大象在内的军队翻越阿尔卑斯山，赢得有史以来最著名的三场战役之一，屠杀数量惊人的罗马人，并将罗马逼入绝境。这个故事太史诗了，以至于我猜制作成本会高得让人望而却步。事实上，是玛丽娜·海德——她关注了我的娱乐事业——让我知道了范·迪塞尔对汉尼拔的热情，她对此作出了非常风趣的评论：
make these films would cost only marginally less than an independent nuclear deterrent. Oh, that is witty. I think she's not exaggerating. But Vin is obviously still dreaming. That's good because there's a rifle project I read that Denzel Washington, who has dabbled in Swords and Sandals and Gladiator 2, he's ambitious to do a Hannibal epic as well, isn't he? Although there's actually no sign of that coming to the screen either. I think this one may be kind of more in the works. I think it's for Netflix, so it may be coming soon, but I mean, again, no sign of it as yet. Okay. And the thing is I entirely
拍摄这些电影的成本只比独立的核威慑力量略少一点点。哦，真风趣。我觉得她一点也没有夸张。但范显然还在做着这个梦。这挺好的，因为我读到一个项目，丹泽尔·华盛顿也涉足过剑阀沙和《角斗士2》，他也有雄心拍摄一部汉尼拔史诗片，不是吗？尽管目前实际上也没有任何要上映的迹象。我觉得这个项目可能已经在筹备中了。我想它是为网飞（Netflix）制作的，所以可能很快就会上映，但我的意思是，同样，目前还没有任何迹象。好吧。问题是，我完全
understand the obsession because it's one I completely share. And if I were a massive Hollywood star, I would be pushing to do a Hannibal film as well, because basically I would say, we're going to be doing this series on Hannibal. This is what I've been looking forward to doing since we began the podcast. And if you'd asked me when I was eight, what would I want to be doing when I'm 57? This is basically it. Who wouldn't be a podcast at Chatham high street. No Hannibal even more than Chatham High Street, because I think this is one of
理解这种痴迷，因为这也是我完全感同身受的。如果我是个好莱坞大腕，我也会极力主张拍一部汉尼拔电影，因为基本上我会说：“我们要拍这个关于汉尼拔的系列节目。这是我从开始做这个播客以来一直期待做的事情。如果你在我八岁时问我，57岁时我想做什么？基本上就是这个。”谁不想在查塔姆高街（Chatham High Street）做一个播客呢？不，比起查塔姆高街，大家更想要汉尼拔，因为我认为这是
the greatest stories, not just ancient history, but history full stop. So for people who don't know, this is the story of the Second Punic War fought at the end of the third century BC. That's right, isn't it? Yeah. 218 to 201. And it's between Carthage, the great sea power of the Mediterranean, North African power, and the emerging superpower Carthage, the great sea power of the Mediterranean, North African power and the emerging superpower of Rome. The Roman historian Livy called it the most memorable war in history. Tom, do you think it does? Well, you obviously do, given your enthusiasm for it.
最伟大的故事之一，不仅是古代史，甚至是整个历史中都数一数二的。所以对于不了解的人来说，这是关于公元前三世纪末爆发的第二次布匿战争的故事。对吧？是的。公元前218年到201年。交战双方是迦太基——地中海伟大的海上强国、北非强权，以及正在崛起的新兴超级大国——迦太基是地中海伟大的海上强国、北非强权，以及正在崛起的新兴超级大国罗马。罗马历史学家李维称其为历史上最令人难忘的战争。汤姆，你觉得是吗？好吧，鉴于你对它满腔热情，你显然是这么认为的。
It's up there with Alexander the Great or with the war between Athens and Sparta or the Persian. I mean, arguably an even greater story because it has this extraordinary protagonist in Hannibal himself. Hannibal is up there with Alexander as one of the great commanders of ancient history of all time, but I think it has a kind of more tragic quality than the story of Alexander because Hannibal's desire to take on Rome is inspired less by a longing for glory and conquest. Carthage is a much less militarist society than Macedon or even more Rome and kind of more for a desire to save his city from a threat that he knows is only
它足以与亚历山大大帝、雅典与斯巴达之间的战争或波斯战争相提并论。甚至可以说是一个更伟大的故事，因为它有汉尼拔这样一个非凡的主角。汉尼拔和亚历山大一样，是古代史上乃至有史以来最伟大的统帅之一，但我认为它比亚历山大的故事有一种更具悲剧色彩的特质，因为汉尼拔向罗马发起挑战的愿望，与其说是出于对荣耀和征服的渴望——迦太基是一个远不如马其顿甚至更不如罗马那样好战的社会——倒不如说是为了拯救他的城市，免受他明知只会
going to be growing, namely Rome. And also undoubtedly he wants revenge because Carthage has already received a very bloody nose from Rome. And the tragic element is that his very attempt to try and defeat Rome and thereby save his city in the long run dooms it. And this is the second series about Carthage. So we will in due course be coming to the story about how Rome triumphs over Carthage and ends up burning it to the ground. But in this series, fans of Carthage, fans of Hannibal can just sit back and enjoy the ride because everything in this is Hannibal at his absolute peak. Everything's going brilliantly for him. So we're going to be covering his invasion of Italy, the Alps, the elephants, all of that. We're going to be looking at his first two great victories
不断壮大的威胁（即罗马）的侵害。毫无疑问，他也想要复仇，因为迦太基之前已经被罗马狠狠地羞辱过了。而悲剧的元素在于，他试图击败罗马并从而长远地拯救自己城市的尝试，最终却注定了城市的毁灭。这是关于迦太基的第二个系列节目。因此，我们将在适当的时候讲述罗马如何战胜迦太基并最终将其烧为平地。但在这个系列中，迦太基的粉丝们、汉尼拔的粉丝们可以坐下来好好享受这段旅程，因为这里的一切都是汉尼拔的绝对巅峰。一切对他的发展都极其顺利。所以我们将介绍他入侵意大利、阿尔卑斯山、大象以及所有这些内容。我们还将回顾他在特雷比亚河和特拉西梅诺湖赢得的前两场伟大胜利。
that he wins at the river Trebia and Lake Trasimene. Then he has a cat and mouse game with a Roman dictator who's appointed to save Rome in the teeth of disaster, Fabius the Delayer. And then we will be culminating in our final episode in Rome's bloodiest and most terrible defeat at the Battle of Cannae. So it is non-stop drama. Very exciting and if you're a member of the Restless History Club of course you can hear all those episodes right now. But before we come to Hannibal himself, this character at the centre of the drama, let's have a little bit of a recap for people who didn't listen to our first series about Carthage and Rome or perhaps have forgotten some of the details. So Carthage is a much more long established power than Rome, isn't it?
接着，他将与一位在灾难当头时被任命来拯救罗马的罗马独裁官——“延宕者”费边——展开一场猫鼠游戏。最后，我们将在最后一节以罗马最血腥、最可怕的惨败——坎尼战役——作为高潮。所以这是不间断的戏剧性高潮。非常令人兴奋，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你当然可以现在就收听所有这些剧集。但在我们介绍汉尼拔本人——这个处于戏剧中心的人物——之前，让我们先为那些没有听过我们关于迦太基和罗马的第一系列节目，或者可能已经忘记了一些细节的人做一个小小的回顾。所以，迦太基是一个比罗马历史悠久得多的强权，对吧？
It's on the North coast of Africa. It's supposedly founded in 814 BC. So it's been going for about 500 years or so. And it's settled by emigrants from what is now Lebanon, from Tyre. Yeah. And so they call it the new city, which in Punic, the language spoken by the Phoenicians and the Carthaginians is Carthadash. So that becomes Carthage and it has every advantage going for it. So it has magnificent natural harbors.
它位于非洲北海岸。据说是建于公元前814年。所以它已经存在了大约500年左右。那里的定居者来自现在的黎巴嫩，来自推罗（Tyre）。是的。因此他们称之为“新城”，用腓尼基人和迦太基人说的布匿语来说就是“Carthadash”。这就变成了迦太基，它占尽了各种优势。因此它拥有壮丽的天然良港。
It has very fertile hinterland so it can be fed very easily. And essentially today the ruins of Carthage are part of the suburbs of the city of Tunis. And so that means that it can command the crucial straits in the Mediterranean between what is now Tunisia and Sicily. And for centuries you mentioned that Carthage is a great naval power. It is by miles the most formidable and the richest naval power in the Western Mediterranean. And in the third century BC, the beginning of the third century BC, it has an empire that includes much of North Africa, a chunk of Sicily, it has Corsica, it has Sardinia, and it's also the mistress of a whole array of Phoenician colonies that dot the kind of southern coast of Iberia, of Spain.
它拥有非常肥沃的腹地，因此可以轻而易举地获得粮食补给。本质上，今天的迦太基废墟就是突尼斯市郊的一部分。这意味着它能够掌控地中海的关键海峡，即现在的突尼斯和西西里岛之间的海峡。几个世纪以来，你提到迦太基是一个伟大的海军强国。它绝对是西地中海最令人生畏、最富有的海军强国。在公元前三世纪，公元前三世纪初，它的帝国包括大部分北非、西西里岛的一部分、科西嘉岛、萨丁尼亚岛，它还是点缀在伊比利亚（即西班牙）南部海岸的一系列腓尼基殖民地的霸主。
Right. But then when we get to the early third century BC, so the two eighties, seventies, two sixties, there's a growing tension with a new kid on the block, the emerging new land power, military power, which is Rome. And that gives rise to the first Punic war, which we talked about last time, which starts in 264, I think. Is that right? Yeah. And as you said, Rome is the great military power. So it's the elephant against the whale. It's a military power against predominantly a naval power. And partly because
没错。但当我们进入公元前三世纪初，也就是公元前280年代、270年代、260年代时，与一个新崛起的新兴陆地强权、军事强权——罗马——之间的紧张局势日益加剧。这就引发了第一次布匿战争，我们上次谈到过，它始于公元前264年，我想是这样吧？是的。正如你所说，罗马是伟大的军事强国。所以这是一场大象对阵鲸鱼的较量。军事强权对阵主要的海军强国。部分原因是
the determination not to yield on both sides is completely implacable. The war just goes on and on and on 23 years in all. So it's the longest continuous war in the whole of antiquity. It bleeds both sides white in terms of manpower and in terms of wealth, but in the end it is the Carthaginians who are forced to sue for terms and in 241 a treaty is signed that ends the war and by its terms Carthage surrenders all its holdings in Sicily where it had been a major power for centuries and centuries, it has to clear out. And Sicily then becomes the first overseas province ruled by Rome.
双方决不妥协的决心是完全不可动摇的。这场战争没完没了地持续下去，总共长达23年。因此它是整个古代世界中持续时间最长的连续战争。它在人力和财富方面将双方榨干殆尽，但最终是迦太基人被迫求和。公元前241年，双方签署了一份条约结束了战争。根据条约条款，迦太基交出了其在西西里岛的所有领土——它在那里曾是一个延续数个世纪的主要强权，它必须撤出。西西里岛随后成为罗马统治下的第一个海外行省。
So for the first time, Rome is no longer merely an Italian power. Carthage is also obliged to pay a massive indemnity. And the combined effect of these terms imposed on the defeated city essentially is to neutralize her as a naval power. So what had traditionally been her strength? So Carthage hasn't been destroyed, but she's definitely been crippled. And so the obvious question for the Carthaginians is how is she going to come back from this? And this is the great challenge that obsesses her leading men. Right.
因此，罗马破天荒地不再仅仅是一个意大利强权。迦太基还被迫支付了巨额赔偿金。这些强加给战败城市的条款综合起来，基本上起到了解除其海军武装的作用。也就是她传统的优势所在。所以迦太基并没有被摧毁，但她绝对已经被废了武功。因此，对于迦太基人来说，显而易见的问题是：她将如何从这一切中卷土重来？这就是让她的领导人们魂牵梦绕的巨大挑战。没错。
And her leading men, one in particular, will play a part in the story. And this is not yet Hannibal, but it is a man called Hamilcar. Hamilcar Barca. And Barca means the thunderbolt or the lightning bolt or something, doesn't it? Yeah. So expressive of his speed, his ability to incinerate his opponents. Even the Romans acknowledged that Barca, lightning bolt, was an excellent description of him. So to quote Cornelius Nepos, who was writing a couple of centuries afterwards, looking back at this time, he wrote about
而她的领导人们，尤其是其中一位，将在故事中扮演重要角色。这还不是汉尼拔，而是一个名叫哈米尔卡（Hamilcar）的人。哈米尔卡·巴卡（Hamilcar Barca）。“巴卡”的意思是霹雳、闪电或者类似的东西，对吧？是的。这表达了他的速度，以及他将对手化为灰烬的能力。甚至连罗马人都承认，“巴卡”（闪电）是对他极好的描述。因此，引用科尔内利乌斯·尼波斯（Cornelius Nepos）的话——他在几个世纪后写作时回顾了这一时期，他这样写道：
Hamilcar, wherever he had personal command, he would never yield to the enemy nor give them opportunity to inflict damage on his forces. Quite the opposite indeed, for he would often go on the offensive should the opportunity present itself and invariably emerged victorious. And that kind of Roman emphasis on Hamilcar's ability to go on the offensive, firstly, that is a Roman recognizing a Roman quality in a Carthaginian. Most Carthaginians are not aggressive militarily in the way that say a Roman would be, but also I think he is looking ahead to Hamilcar's ability to muster resources in a way that will enable him to prepare for revenge against the Romans for defeating Carthage in the First Punic
关于哈米尔卡，无论他在哪里亲自指挥，他都绝不向敌人屈服，也绝不给敌人机会对他的军队造成损害。恰恰相反，如果机会出现，他往往会主动出击，并且总是能取得胜利。罗马人对哈米尔卡进攻能力的那种强调，首先，这是罗马人在一个迦太基人身上认可了一种罗马式的品质。大多数迦太基人在军事上并不像罗马人那样具有侵略性，但我也认为他是在展望哈米尔卡聚集资源的能力，这种能力将使他能够为向罗马复仇做好准备，因为罗马在第一次布匿战争中击败了迦太基。
War. And Hamilcar himself is a very seasoned Roman fighter. So it's Hamilcar in the dying days of the First Punic War who had led the desperate attempt by the Carthaginians in Sicily to defeat the Romans there. It fails basically because the Carthaginian fleet is defeated and so therefore, Hamilcar can no longer be supplied from Carthage. And when Carthage is thereby forced to surrender in the war, it's Hamilcar who is entrusted by the Carthaginians to negotiate the terms. And people who listen to our episode about this may remember that in the wake of Carthage's defeat, they're so skint that they can't afford to pay the mercenaries who provided them with the bulk of their army. The mercenaries rebel. At one point, it looks
哈米尔卡本人是一位经验丰富的罗马战场老兵。因此，在第一次布匿战争行将结束时，正是在西西里岛率领迦太基人进行绝望抵抗以击败罗马人的人，正是哈米尔卡。抵抗失败了，基本上是因为迦太基舰队战败了，因此，迦太基无法再向哈米尔卡提供补给。当迦太基因此被迫在战争中投降时，正是哈米尔卡被迦太基人委托去谈判停战条款。听过我们关于这一集节目的听众可能还记得，在迦太基战败之后，他们穷得叮当响，甚至付不起那些构成了他们军队主力的大批雇佣兵的薪水。雇佣兵叛变了。有一段时间，看起来
as though Carthage is going to fall to them. And his Hamilcar, who returns from Sicily, leads the campaign against the mercenaries and ends up defeating them and executing them all in very horrible and bloody ways. That was a satisfyingly bloody story was the defeat of the mercenaries. So, I mean, he hates Rome. He has massive, massive unfinished business with Rome, doesn't he? But it's more than just political, it's personal for Hamilcar, is that right? He resents Rome as an opponent in war who has defeated Carthage, so that's understandable.
迦太基就要落入他们手中了。正是从西西里归来的哈米尔卡，领导了针对雇佣兵的战役，最终击败了他们，并以非常可怕和血腥的方式将他们全部处决。击败雇佣兵真是一个令人满意的血腥故事。所以，我的意思是，他恨罗马；他和罗马之间有大量、大量的未了恩怨，对吧？但这不仅是政治上的，对哈米尔卡来说也是私人的，是这样吗？他痛恨罗马这个在战争中击败了迦太基的对手，所以这可以理解。
But in due course, his resentment of that, I think, is definitely spiced by a personal sense of betrayal, because Hamilcar has negotiated these terms with the Romans. And the Romans take advantage of the mercenary war to tighten the screws on Carthage, so essentially exploiting her misfortune. So in 237, that is the year after the defeat of the mercenaries, the Carthaginians want to go and stabilize their position in Sardinia because there have been kind of mercenary uprisings there as well. So they raise an army to go and do that. And the Romans in a display of coarse and brutal cynicism that is entirely typical of their statecraft denounce this army as being in breach of the treaty. They say you're raising this army to come and attack
但在适当的时候，他对这种事的怨恨，我认为绝对夹杂了一种个人的背叛感，因为哈米尔卡与罗马人谈判达成了这些条款。而罗马人却利用雇佣兵战争来对迦太基紧逼不舍，从本质上讲就是剥削她的不幸。所以在公元前237年——也就是雇佣兵战败后的那一年，迦太基人想要去稳定他们在萨丁尼亚的地位，因为那里也发生了某种雇佣兵起义。于是他们集结了一支军队前去处理此事。而罗马人则表现出了一种粗俗而残酷的冷嘲热讽，这完全是他们国家治术的典型代表，他们谴责这支军队违反了条约。他们说你们集结这支军队是为了来攻击
us and so a Roman embassy arrives in Carthage to demand revisions to the peace treaty because they say that the Carthaginians have broken it. They haven't broken it at all. And the Romans say you've got to surrender Sardinia and Corsica to us. This was never part of the original treaty. And we are going to increase the indemnity that you need to pay us. So essentially it is massively exploiting Carthage's hour of need and weakness. And so they have no choice but to accept these terms and Hamilcar is left incredibly embittered. So to quote a historian of the period, resentful of the injustice, but powerless to prevent it.
我们。因此，一个罗马使团抵达迦太基，要求修改和平条约，因为他们声称迦太基人打破了条约。他们根本就没有打破条约。而罗马人则说你们必须把萨丁尼亚和科西嘉割让给我们。这在最初的条约中从来都不是一部分。而且我们还要增加你们需要支付给我们的赔偿金。所以这本质上是在极力榨取迦太基处于危难和虚弱的时刻。因此他们别无选择，只能接受这些条款，而哈米尔卡则满腔悲愤地留了下来。用当时一位历史学家的话说：“满腔对不公的愤慨，却又无力阻止。”
So this is not a kind of man who is going to take it lying down. So how can he go about doing this, Tom, because you said earlier that Carthage has been hamstrung. So how can they plausibly hope to go toe to toe with the Romans once again? Well, so they've lost their land empire in Sicily, in Sardinia and Corsica, but there is another obvious place where Hamilcar can start building a power center and this is Spain. So I mentioned that Phoenician colonies have been planted along the southern coast of Spain
所以这绝不是那种会逆来顺受的人。那么他该如何着手做这件事呢，汤姆？因为你刚才说过迦太基已经被绑住了手脚。那么他们怎么能貌似合理地希望再次与罗马正面交锋呢？嗯，所以他们在西西里、萨丁尼亚和科西嘉的陆地帝国已经失去了，但还有一个显而易见的地方可以让哈米尔卡开始建立权力中心，这就是西班牙。所以我提到过，腓尼基人的殖民地一直散布在西班牙南部海岸，
and actually beyond the pillars of Hercules, so the straits of Gibraltar, probably the oldest of the lot is a Gardez which will become Cadiz. And these settlements are very strategically positioned. So as with Carthage, very rich agricultural hinterland, so there's opportunity there to expand but even more, it is potentially incredibly rich because there are a lot of precious minerals just waiting to be mined. And also, if these minerals can be kind of turned into gold to pay for mercenaries, to conquer more territory, then that conquered territory can supply further troops because Spain is obviously a massive, massive reserve of manpower.
实际上越过了海格力斯之柱（即直布罗陀海峡），其中大概最古老的就是加迪斯（Gades），后来将成为加的斯（Cadiz）。这些定居点的位置极具战略意义。就像迦太基一样，那里拥有非常肥沃的农业腹地，因此有扩张的机会；但更重要的是，它潜在地极其富裕，因为有大量的贵金属正等待被开采。而且，如果这些矿产能够变成黄金，用来支付雇佣兵的薪水以征服更多领土，那么被征服的领土就可以提供更多的军队，因为西班牙显然是一个庞大无比的人力储备库。
Carthage has never actually established a land empire in Spain, to repeat, it is not a city that is interested in establishing kind of direct rule over vast swathes of territory in the way that the Romans have shown themselves to be. But Hamilcar, having looked at the way that Rome has risen to power, recognizes, I think, that the only way that Carthage can really survive, let alone defeat the Romans, is to play that game as well. And so his plan essentially is to transform the kind of loose hegemony that Carthage had always exercised over these Phoenician colonies in Spain into a kind of direct rule, and then using these Phoenician ports as bases to expand inland and carve out a
迦太基其实从未真正在西班牙建立过一个陆地帝国。重申一下，它并不是一个对建立跨越大片领土的直接统治感兴趣的城市——就像罗马人已经表现出的那样。但哈米尔卡在观察了罗马崛起的方式后，认识到迦太基要想真正生存下来，更不用说击败罗马，唯一的办法就是也玩这种游戏。因此，他的计划本质上是将迦太基历来对西班牙这些腓尼基殖民地施加的那种松散的霸权，转变为一种直接统治，然后以这些腓尼基港口为基地向内陆扩张，开辟出一个
Spanish dominion that will be able to replace the empire lost in Sicily, Sardinia and Corsica and hopefully to provide even greater reserves because of the mineral wealth and the possible reserves of manpower. So on paper, this looks like a brilliant plan, right? You can get the silver and the minerals from Spain, or you can pick up mercenaries and conscripts from the Iberian peoples. You'll be militarily stronger, you'll be financially stronger, and you can basically begin to rebuild your reputation and you can plausibly hope to have another go at
西班牙领地，以此来取代在西西里、萨丁尼亚和科西嘉失去的帝国，并且由于其矿产财富和潜在的人力储备，有望提供更强大的资源储备。所以，纸面上看，这似乎是个绝妙的计划，对吧？你可以从西班牙获得白银和矿产，或者你可以从伊比利亚各民族那里招募雇佣兵和应征兵。你的军事实力会更强，财政实力会更强，你基本上就可以开始重建你的声誉，并且可以貌似合理地希望以后再跟
the Romans later on. And it's also good for Hamilcar personally, isn't it? Because if he's able to pull this off, it will entrench his position as the big man in the state. Does he want to create a dynasty? I think almost certainly. Politics in Carthage is pretty carnivorous. The penalty for failure is very serious. Generals who lose battles are often crucified. So I think for Hamilcar, who has had personal experience of people trying to stab him in the back while he's been busy fighting the Romans, I think the chance of establishing a great center of power, not just for Carthage, but for himself
罗马人较量一番。而且这对哈米尔卡个人也有好处，不是吗？因为如果他能成功做到这一点，将巩固他作为国家大佬的地位。他想建立一个王朝吗？我几乎可以肯定是的。迦太基的政治相当残酷。失败的惩罚非常严重。打败仗的将军经常会被钉死在十字架上。所以对于哈米尔卡来说——他有着在忙于与罗马人作战时被人从背后捅刀子的亲身经历，我认为建立一个巨大的权力中心的机会，不仅是为了迦太基，也是为了他自己
and establishing a dynasty there, you know, win-win, everything is great about it. And it's very clear that Hamilcar is an extremely enthusiastic family man. So we know he has at least three daughters. We don't know their names, but we do know that one of them is married off to Hamilcar's closest political ally in Carthage, who is a guy called Hastrable the Handsome. And people who remember our first series may also remember the fact that basically there are only about three names in Carthage, of which Hasdrubal is probably the most common. So this is Hasdrubal the handsome because he's such a good looking guy. So good news for Hamilcar's daughter.
并在那里建立一个王朝，你知道的，双赢，一切都好。而且很明显，哈米尔卡是一个极其热心的顾家好男人。我们知道他至少有三个女儿。我们不知道她们的名字，但我们确实知道其中一个嫁给了哈米尔卡在迦太基最亲密的政治盟友——一个名叫“美男子哈斯德鲁巴”（Hasdrubal the Handsome）的人。还记得我们第一个系列节目的听众可能也记得这样一个事实：基本上迦太基只有大约三个名字，其中哈斯德鲁巴可能是最常见的。所以这是“美男子哈斯德鲁巴”，因为他长得太帅了。这对哈米尔卡的女儿来说是个好消息。
And in 237, when Hamilcar leaves Carthage for Spain, Hasdrubal is sailing with him. Hamilcar also has three sons. The youngest of these is called Mago. Then inevitably there's a guy called Hasdrubal. So that's Hamilcar's son. And the oldest is a young lad called Hannibal. This is the Hannibal. So in 237, when Hamilcar is preparing to leave for Spain, Hannibal is only nine years old.
公元前237年，当哈米尔卡离开迦太基前往西班牙时，哈斯德鲁巴也随船同行。哈米尔卡还有三个儿子。其中最小的叫马戈（Mago）。然后不可避免地，有一个人也叫哈斯德鲁巴——那是哈米尔卡的儿子。而老大是一个名叫汉尼拔的小男孩。这就是那个汉尼拔。所以在公元前237年，当哈米尔卡准备动身前往西班牙时，汉尼拔只有九岁。
And you might think, you know, that's probably too young to be taken to a war zone, but Hamilcar thinks not. And there is a very, very famous anecdote with which we finished our last series on Carthage, but I think it bears repeating because it is very, very revealing about what will motivate Hannibal. And he tells it to various people later in life, so it almost certainly comes from his own lips. And he describes how he joins his father in the great temple of Baal in Carthage, where his father is making sacrifice. And this is supposedly how Hannibal described it. The omens proved favorable. Hamilcar poured a libation to the gods and performed the customary ceremonies, after
你可能会想，那可能太小了，不适合带去战区，但哈米尔卡不这么认为。有一个非常非常著名的轶事，我们用它结束了上一期关于迦太基的系列节目，但我觉得它值得重复，因为它非常非常具有启示意义，能说明汉尼拔的动力源泉是什么。他在后来的生活中向许多人讲述过这件事，所以它几乎肯定出自他自己的亲口。他描述了自己如何在迦太基的巴力（Baal）大神庙里加入他的父亲，当时他的父亲正在进行献祭。据称汉尼拔是这样描述的：预兆显示吉利。哈米尔卡向诸神倾倒奠酒并举行了常规仪式，此后
which he ordered all those who were present at the sacrifice to stand back a little away from the altar. Then he called Hannibal to him and asked him affectionately whether he wished to accompany the expedition, so that's to Spain. Hannibal was overjoyed to accept and, like a boy, begged to be allowed to go. His father then took him by the hand, led him up to the altar and commanded him to lay his hand upon the victim and swear an oath that he would never become a friend to the Romans. Strong stuff. Strong stuff. And it's a promise that he will keep all his life. And you think this is probably true because Hannibal tells himself. It probably
他命令所有出席献祭的人从祭坛旁退后一段距离。然后他把汉尼拔叫到身边，亲切地问他是否愿意随军出征——也就是去西班牙。汉尼拔欣喜若狂地接受了，像个小男孩一样恳求让他去。他的父亲随后拉起他的手，领他走到祭坛前，命令他将手按在祭品上，并庄严发誓，永远不成为罗马人的朋友。够劲爆。够劲爆。这是一个他将信守一生的承诺。你会觉得这很可能是真的，因为汉尼拔自己也这么说。这很可能
is. Yeah. Okay. So first of all, he has to go to Spain and actually this is an unbelievable thing. He goes to Spain at the age of nine and he will not return to Carthage until he's 42. Is that right? Yeah. He is raised in this colonial environment, this process of conquest, then of rule in Spain. Yeah. And in due course, he will come conquest, then of rule in Spain. Yeah.
是真的。嗯。好吧。首先，他必须去西班牙。实际上这是一件不可思议的事情。他在九岁时去了西班牙，直到42岁才返回迦太基。是这样吗？是的。他在这种殖民环境中长大，经历了征服，然后在西班牙进行统治。是的。在适的时候，他将
And in due course, he will come to take command of it. But first, of course, he has to serve his apprenticeship. And he does this under two formidable men in succession. And the first, of course, is his father, Hamilcar Barca. And even though Hamilcar is probably the most formidable man in Carthage, there's no guarantee of success. He doesn't have that many men. This is Carthage's whole problem that they don't have a huge citizen body.
开始掌控这一切。但首先，当然，他必须经历学徒期。他是在两位极为强大的前辈手下相继完成这一过程的。首先，当然是他的父亲哈米尔卡·巴卡。尽管哈米尔卡可能是迦太基最强大的人物，但这并不能保证成功。他没有那么多手下。这就是迦太基的全部问题所在——他们没有庞大的公民群体。
So generally they rely on mercenaries, but now they don't have much money. So they can't afford many mercenaries. So the estimation of Dexter Hoyos in his very good book on this Hannibal's dynasty, he reckons probably Hamilcar is sailing to Spain with about 20,000 men. So not that many at all. And it's not surprising that being so, he needs money. He sails to Gades and what he wants is the silver and copper mines along the Rio Tinto that lie about 60 miles inland from Gades and which is rich across the whole of the Mediterranean. So it features in the Bible as Tarshish, a land of fabled wealth. According to tradition,
因此他们通常依赖雇佣兵，但现在他们没有多少钱。所以他们雇不起很多雇佣兵。根据德克斯特·霍约斯（Dexter Hoyos）在他那本关于汉尼拔王朝的优秀著作中的估计，他认为哈米尔卡率领大约两万人航行到西班牙。所以根本没有多少人。鉴于此，他需要钱也就不足为奇了。他航行到加迪斯，他想要的是里奥坦托（Rio Tinto）沿岸的白银和铜矿——这些矿藏位于加迪斯内陆约60英里处，在地中海各地都极为富饶。因此它在《圣经》中被称为他施（Tarshish），一片充满传奇财富的土地。根据传统，
the tribes who live there are so rich that their cattle troughs are made of silver. So obviously if you're a colonial administrator and desperately need of cash, this is exactly the kind of place that you would go straight for. And he does meet with opposition. Yeah. The good news for him though is that though they're rich, they're not as good at fighting as he is, right? He will sort of encircle them won't he?
那里的部族如此富有，以至于他们的牛槽都是用白银做的。所以很明显，如果你是一个急需现金的殖民地行政官，这正是你会径直前往的那种地方。他的确遇到了抵抗。是的。不过对他的好消息是，尽管他们很富有，但他们的战斗力不如他，对吧？他会以某种方式包围他们，不是吗？
That's his strategy. He encircles them and then he completely massacres them. I mean, he's a pretty ferocious man, Hamilcar Barca. Yes. The strategy of surrounding your enemies and then massacring them. And if young Hannibal is at his side when he's pursuing these tactics, I mean, this is something that clearly
这就是他的战略。他包围他们，然后将他们彻底屠杀。我的意思是一个相当凶猛的人，哈米尔卡·巴卡。是的。包围敌人然后将其屠杀的战略。如果年轻的汉尼拔在实施这些战术时陪伴在他身旁，我的意思是，这显然是
Hannibal will bear in mind in due course because it becomes a favorite tactic of Hannibal himself. And Hamilcar is very brutal in the process of conquering and pacifying Spain. So the leaders of tribes who oppose him are tortured and crucified and the Cartaginians are very good at torture, as anyone who's listened to our episode on the war with the mercenaries will know. And the men of the tribes that have been defeated will be enrolled into his own forces and they will be given
汉尼拔在适的时候会牢记在心的东西，因为它后来成了汉尼拔本人最喜爱的战术。哈米尔卡在征服和安抚西班牙的过程中非常残酷。因此，那些反对他的部族首领会遭受酷刑并被钉死在十字架上——迦太基人非常擅长酷刑，正如任何听过我们关于与雇佣兵战争那一集节目的听众所知的那样。而被击败的部族的人会被编入他自己的军队，并会获得
incredibly lavish pay. So this is the other side of the conquest that Hamilcar is very brutal to those who oppose him. Those who back him, he will lavish all the gold that he's annexed and conquered. And so this enables him to start spreading Carthaginian rule inland from the coast. And after about a decade of operations in Spain, Hamilcar has a garrison there that's probably around 50,000 men. So he's more than doubled it in the space of a decade. And he's incredibly wealthy.
极其丰厚的报酬。所以这是征服的另一面——哈米尔卡对那些反抗他的人极其残酷；而对于那些支持他的人，他会慷慨赏赐他所吞并和征服的所有黄金。这使他得以开始将迦太基的统治从海岸向内陆蔓延。在西班牙进行了大约十年的行动后，哈米尔卡在那里的驻军大概达到了五万人左右。所以他在十年内将兵力翻了一番还多。而且他极其富有。
His coffers are overflowing with silver. And unsurprisingly, the Romans are not really very thrilled about this. So by 231, they're sufficiently alarmed that they send an embassy to Hamilcar basically saying, you know, Hey, what's going on here? Hamilcar, his reply is, well, I'm raising funds to pay off the war indemnity that you illegally raised. And, you know, the Romans have to suck this up, right? Because I mean, it's a good reply. And also, you know,
他的国库里堆满了白银。毫无疑问，罗马人对此并不是很高兴。因此，到了公元前231年，他们感到足够惊恐，于是派了一个使团去见哈米尔卡，基本上是说：“喂，这里发生什么事了？”哈米尔卡的回答是：“哦，我正在筹集资金来偿还你们非法的战争赔偿金。”而且，你知道的，罗马人只能把这口气咽下去，对吧？因为我的意思是，这是一个很好的回答。而且，你知道的，
as Hamilcar can point out, it's none of their business what he's getting up to in Spain. You know, this isn't covered by the treaty. So the Roman ambassadors, you know, as Hamilcar can point out, it's none of their business what he's getting up to in Spain. You know, this isn't covered by the treaty. So the Roman ambassadors, you know, they're forced to bite their tongues and go back and accept the existence of this growing Carthaginian Empire in Spain. But then a bad blow for Hamilcar. What a very bad blow. The worst. He dies in battle against whom?
正如哈米尔卡所指出的，他在西班牙搞什么名堂根本不管他们的事。你知道的，这不在条约的涵盖范围之内。所以罗马大使们，正如哈米尔卡所指出的，他们在西班牙搞什么名堂根本不管他们的事。你知道的，这不在条约的涵盖范围之内。所以罗马大使们，你知道的，他们被迫打碎牙齿往肚里咽，回去接受这个在西班牙不断壮大的迦太基帝国的存在。但随后对哈米尔卡来说是一个沉重的打击。多么沉重的打击啊。最沉重的打击。他在与谁的战斗中阵亡了？
Against a Spanish tribe in the interior and the stories about how he dies become ever more extravagant as time goes by. So one historian is relatively close in time to the event and tends to be more sober. He reports in very vague terms that Hamilcar ended his career in a manner which formed a fitting climax to his achievements for he lost his life after fighting gallantly and with complete disregard for his personal safety in a battle against one of the strongest and most warlike of the tribes. So it's a good death. It's a heroic death. But accounts of exactly how he dies then start to get inflated. So a later report says that he is betrayed by a local chieftain while undertaking a siege, that Hamilcar's forces are taken
与内陆的一个西班牙部族交战时阵亡了，关于他如何死去的传说随着时间的推移变得越来越夸张。因此，一位距离事件发生时间相对较近、往往更为稳重的历史学家以非常含糊的措辞报道说，哈米尔卡以一种与其成就相得益彰的方式结束了他的职业生涯，因为他在与最强大、最好战的部族之一的战斗中英勇作战，全然不顾个人安危，最终失去了生命。所以这是一个壮烈的死法，一个英雄的死法。但关于他具体如何死去的说法随后开始被夸大。因此，一份后来的报道称，他在进行围城战时被当地酋长背叛，哈米尔卡的军队遭到
by surprise and they're forced to withdraw, that his two elder sons, so that's Hannibal and Hamilcar, they are sent off by Hamilcar along one road and he then deliberately draws away the mass of the enemy by taking another road. He's about to be overtaken by his pursuers and ahead of him there's a raging river and he plunges into the river on his horse and drowns. So essentially he sacrifices himself for his two sons. I mean, whether true or not, we don't know. But he's like a kind of a lion defending his cubs. I think that's dying rather than seeing his cubs exterminated. That's the theme.
袭击并被迫撤退，他的两个大儿子——也就是汉尼拔和哈米尔卡——被哈米尔卡派往一条道路，而他自己则故意通过走另一条道路来引开主力敌人。他即将被追兵追上，他前方是一条汹涌的河流，他骑着马冲进河里淹死了。因此，本质上他是为了两个儿子而牺牲了自己。我的意思是，是真是假，我们不得而知。但他就像一头保护幼崽的狮子。我认为这是宁可死去也不愿看到幼崽被消灭。这就是主题。
There's an element with him, isn't there, of the Philip of Macedon, Philip II. For sure. Yeah. So he ends up being famous as Hannibal's father, but in both cases, you can argue the son's achievements are completely predicated on the successes of their father. So in both cases, their father leaves them with a lot of silver, a military machine, a load of officers they can rely on, a sense of prestige, all the groundwork has been done basically.
他身上有一种马其顿的腓力二世（Philip II of Macedon）的影子，不是吗？确实如此。所以他最终作为汉尼拔的父亲而闻名，但在两个案例中，你可以说儿子的成就是完全建立在他们父亲的成功之上的。因此，在这两个案例中，他们的父亲给他们留下了大量的白银、一台战争机器、一群他们可以信赖的军官、一种声望感，基本上所有的基础工作都做好了。
Yeah, and a kind of military education as well. I mean, there is a difference though, that Hannibal, unlike Alexander, doesn't succeed his father immediately because he's still only 18. He's not a king, you know, they don't have kings. So the leader of the Carthaginians in Spain is an elected post, essentially by the army, by the Carthaginians in Spain is an elected post essentially by the army, by the Carthaginians in the army. And I think that people feel well an 18 year old, he's too young. So they opt instead for Hasdrubal the Handsome, who is the young Hannibal's brother-in-law, Hasdrubal's son-in-law, very good looking, Hannibal Carr's close political ally, has
是的，还有一种军事教育。不过，确实有一个区别，那就是汉尼拔与亚历山大不同，他没有立即继承父亲的王位，因为他当时只有18岁。他不是国王，你知道的，他们没有国王。因此，迦太基人在西班牙的领袖是由军队选举产生的职位，基本上是由军队中的迦太基人选举产生的领袖。而且我认为人们觉得一个18岁的年轻人太年轻了。所以他们转而选择了美男子哈斯德鲁巴，他是年轻汉尼拔的姐夫（或妹夫）、哈斯德鲁巴（原文如此，应为哈米尔卡）的女婿、长相英俊、是哈米尔卡亲密的政治盟友，
been with him in Spain, knows the ropes and Hamilcar the handsome is very effective. I mean, he's a worthy successor to Hamilcar and like Hamilcar had done, he kind of adopts this carrot and stick approach to the Iberians, to the peoples of Spain. So he marries the daughter of an Iberian king. So you asked about the dynastic quality. I mean, there's a sense that this Carthaginian dynasty is starting to marry into local royalty. He has himself proclaimed not just by the Carthaginians who have voted for him, but by the Iberians as general with unlimited power. So he's rooting his authority in the colonized as well as the colonizers. And even
曾在西班牙与他共事，懂得内情，而且“美男子”哈米尔卡（译者注：原文如此，口误将Hasdrubal说成了Hamilcar）非常有效率。我的意思是，他是一个值得称道的哈米尔卡的继任者，就像哈米尔卡所做的那样，他对待伊比利亚人、西班牙各族人民采取了这种胡萝卜加大棒的方法。所以他娶了一位伊比利亚国王的女儿。所以你问到了王朝的特质。我的意思是，有一种感觉，这个迦太基王朝开始与当地王室联姻。他不仅让自己被投票支持他的迦太基人宣告为拥有无限权力的将军，还被伊比利亚人这样宣告。所以他将自己的权威根植于被殖民者以及殖民者之中。甚至
as he's doing that, he's continuing this policy of absolutely brutal suppression of any hint of rebellion. And his first target obviously is the tribe that had killed Amalcar. They all get wiped out. So he is able to push Carthaginian control ever northwards towards the river Tagus, which is the great river that kind of flows through central Spain. And this empire needs a new capital, Hasdrubal decides. And so this is what he does. He founds a new capital and he calls it stunning originality Carthage, which of course means new city.
在他这样做的同时，他继续对任何叛乱迹象进行绝对残酷镇压的政策。他的第一个目标显然是杀死阿迈尔卡（应为哈米尔卡）的部族。他们全都被消灭了。因此，他得以将迦太基的控制权不断向北推进，直逼塔霍河（Tagus）——那是流经西班牙中部的一条大河。哈斯德鲁巴决定，这个帝国需要一个新的首都。于是他便这么做了。他建立了一个新首都，并以惊人的原创力将其命名为“迦太基”，当然这意味着“新城”。
But the Romans in due course will call it new Carthage, which effectively would be new new city, but we'll call it new Carthage because otherwise it's very confusing, but the Carthaginians in Spain just called it Carthage. Okay. And this is now in Spain. Yeah. So it's Cartagena. Yes.
但罗马人在适当的时候会把它叫做“新迦太基”，实际上这就成了“新新城”，但我们还是叫它“新迦太基”，否则会非常混乱，不过在西班牙的迦太基人只是把它叫做迦太基。好的。而这现在是在西班牙。是的。所以这就是卡塔赫纳（Cartagena）。是的。
Yeah. Which to this day, I gather is still one of the kind of the main centers of the Spanish Navy. So it's clearly as the original Carthage is, a natural port, a great stronghold. And it stands, there are kind of four hills dotted around this great natural harbor. On the largest of these, Hasdrubal builds a great temple to the Carthaginian god of healing. And on the second largest, he builds his own vast palace, which is adorned with all the wealth of of Spain.
据我所知，直到今天，它仍然是西班牙海军的主要中心之一。所以显然，正如最初的迦太基一样，它是一个天然港口，一个巨大的据点。它耸立在那里，这个巨大的天然良港周围点缀着大约四座山丘。在其中最大的山丘上，哈斯德鲁巴为迦太基的医疗之神建造了一座宏伟的神庙。在第二大的山丘上，他建造了自己庞大的宫殿，里面装饰着西班牙所有的财富。
And from there, he can sit and look down at the harbor and see growing numbers of ships, some of the military, but lots of the merchant ships swelling his coffers. He's got the silver mines inland, he's got the shipping routes descending on his great capital. He's able to employ the most cutting edge military architects to build him walls around the city. And so it's not surprising that it comes to be hailed by a near contemporary as the chief ornament and the center of the Carthaginian Empire in Spain. So by the end of the 220s, the Carthaginians are back.
从那里，他可以坐着俯视港口，看着越来越多的船只——有些是军舰，但有很多是商船——充盈着他的国库。他拥有内陆的银矿，拥有涌向他伟大首都的航运路线。他能够聘请最前沿的军事建筑师为他建造环城墙。因此，它被一个近乎同时代的人赞誉为西班牙迦太基帝国的主要装饰和中心，也就不足为奇了。因此，到了公元前220年代末，迦太基人卷土重来了。
I mean, they have an empire now, they have a land colony, they have a lot of money, they have all the silver, they have an empire now, they have a land colony, they have a lot of money, they have all the silver, they have recruits, they have rebuilt a lot of what they'd lost in the first Punic War against the Romans. Why therefore have very few listeners to this bug last heard of Hasdrubal? What happened to him? In 221 BC, he gets assassinated by the slave of a disgruntled Iberian ally. Oh, okay. And so, you know, that's the end of him. Yeah. But as you say, he has absolutely played his part in reconstituting Carthaginian power, possibly on a scale that is even greater than the power that Carthage had
我的意思是，他们现在拥有了一个帝国，他们拥有了一个陆地殖民地，他们有很多钱，他们拥有所有的白银，招募了新兵，重建了他们在与罗马的第一次布匿战争中失去的大部分东西。因此，为什么很少有听众最后听说过哈斯德鲁巴？他怎么了？公元前221年，他被一个心怀不满的伊比利亚盟友的奴隶刺杀了。哦，好吧。所以，你知道的，他的人生就此结束了。是的。但正如你所说，他在重组迦太基实力方面绝对发挥了自己的作用，其规模可能甚至比迦太基在与罗马第一次战争之前所享有的实力还要宏大。我的意思是，绝对地，迦太基回来了。它是一个大国。它可以再次与罗马针锋相对，但这里显然存在着一个轻微的矛盾，那就是所有的权现在都集中在西班牙，而非洲本土的迦太基相比之下显得有些苍白无力。它缺乏储备。它缺乏现在开始在新迦太基发展起来的财富。
enjoyed before the first war with Rome. I mean, so absolutely Carthage is back. She's a great power. She can go eyeball to eyeball with Rome again, but there is obviously a slight paradox here, which is that all the power is now focused in Spain and Carthage herself back in Africa is slightly pallid in comparison. It lacks the reserves. It lacks the wealth that is now starting to develop in New Carthage.
在与罗马的第一场战争之前就已经享有过了。我的意思是，绝对的，迦太基回来了。她是一个大国。她可以再次与罗马针锋相对，但这里显然存在一点悖论，那就是现在所有的力量都集中在西班牙，而迦太基本土在非洲相比之下就略显逊色了。它缺乏新迦太基现在开始发展的那种储备和财富。
So that means that whoever is elected by the Carthaginian army to succeed Hasdrubal as the leader of Carthaginian power in Spain, is probably in a position to prosecute almost an independent foreign policy. The fact that it had always been a problem for the Carthaginian ability to project wars that the Senate back in Carthage is full of kind of rival power brokers who all hate each other. Now the barkids, the dynasty of Hamilcar Barker, they don't have to worry about that. They have their wealth, they have their army, they can essentially do what they like. And so obviously the crucial issue now is who will succeed Hasdrubal the Handsome, who will take
这意味着，无论是谁被迦太基军队选举为哈斯德魯巴的继承人，成为迦太基在西班牙势力的领导者，他很可能都处于能够推行几乎独立的外交政策的地位。卡太基本土的元老院充满了各种互相敌对的权力掮客，他们彼此仇视，这一直是迦太基发动战争能力的一个痛点。现在，巴尔卡家族，也就是哈米尔卡·巴尔卡的家族，他们不必担心这一点。他们拥有财富，拥有军队，基本上可以随心所欲。因此，显而易见，当前的关键问题是谁将接替美男子哈斯德鲁巴，谁将接管
command of these incredible military resources. Who indeed, I bet nobody can guess. So we come back after the break to find out if that person is Hannibal. The question of Hasdrubal's successor was quickly decided. The military vote was in favor of the young Hannibal, who was at once escorted to headquarters, where he was unanimously and enthusiastically acclaimed. The old soldiers felt that in the person of this young man, Hamilcar himself was restored to them. In the features and expression of the son's face, the troops saw the father once again, the same dynamism in his look, the same fire in his eyes.
这些令人难以置信的军事资源。确实会是谁呢，我打赌没人能猜到。所以我们在中场休息后回来，看看这个人是不是汉尼拔。关于哈斯德鲁巴继承人的问题很快就有了决定。军队的投票支持年轻的汉尼拔，他随即被护送到总部，在那里他受到了全体一致的热烈欢呼。老兵们觉得，在这个年轻人身上，哈米尔卡本人又回到了他们身边。在儿子面部的特征和表情中，部队再次看到了父亲的身影，同样的眼神充满活力，同样的目光燃烧着火焰。
So that was the Roman historian Livy talking about the election of Hannibal as the new leader of the Carthaginians in Spain, the Carthaginian troops. So a real bombshell there. None of us were expecting that. No one saw that coming. So he's been chosen by the troops. He then gets the seal of approval from the Senate and from the citizens assembly back in Carthage. So there's nobody questioning his legitimacy. We do a lot of succession crises on the rest of history, but this is not one of them. He is in prime position. So let's go in to Hannibal, the character, the man that Vin Diesel wishes to play on film. I mean, does he look like Vin Diesel? What's he look like? What's his
那是罗马历史学家李维在谈论汉尼拔被选为西班牙迦太基人、迦太基军队的新领袖。这真是一个重磅炸弹。我们谁也没有预料到这一点。谁也没有预料到会有这种事。所以他被军队选中了。随后他得到了来自迦太基元老院和公民大会的批准印章。因此没有人对他的合法性提出质疑。我们在历史的其他部分处理了很多继承危机，但这次不是。他处于极好的位置。让我们来了解一下汉尼拔这个人物，这个范·迪塞尔希望在电影中扮演的人。我的意思是，他长得像范·迪塞尔吗？他长什么样？他的
personality? What's his temperament? Tell all Tom. Well, the only physical description we have of Hannibal is Livy's and Livy's writing in the age of Augustus, so almost 200 years after. And Livy says that he has a face expressive of dynamism and fire in his eyes. But this, you know, I mean, it's kind of pretty generic, I guess. He doesn't say whether Hannibal is tall or short, whether he's bearded or clean shaven. There are silver coins that are minted and there's a figure of a man on it that some people have suggested might be Hannibal, but it's almost certainly a god. So we don't really know what Hannibal looked like. You asked, does it look like Vin Diesel or indeed Denzel Washington? Absolutely not, because both of those are not as young as they were. Hannibal is very young. He's only in his mid-twenties.
性格是什么样的？气质怎么样？汤姆，都告诉我们吧。嗯，我们对汉尼拔仅有的外貌描述来自李维，而李维写作的时代是奥古斯都时期，几乎是在两百年之后。李维说他有一张充满活力、目光中燃烧着火焰的脸。但你知道的，我的意思是，这有点太笼统了，我想。他没有说汉尼拔是高是矮，是有胡子还是刮得干干净净。有一些铸造的银币上面有一个人的形象，有些人暗示这可能是汉尼拔，但几乎可以肯定是一个神。所以我们真的不知道汉尼拔长什么样。你问过他长得像范·迪塞尔还是丹泽尔·华盛顿吗？绝对不像，因为这两个人都不如以前年轻了。汉尼拔非常年轻。他才二十岁出头。
We know on top of that that Hannibal was proud of his descent from one of the original colonists that had settled Carthage way back in the dawn of time when they had sailed from Tyre. So presumably, I mean, he has a kind of look of the Lebanese, maybe a young Nassim Nicholas Taleb, perhaps. Well, when I read this, I had a look, I looked for famous Lebanese celebrities. And you know, the Hollywood star who was born to play him, who was of Lebanese descent himself, Vince Vaughan.
除此之外，我们知道汉尼拔为自己是远古时期从泰尔起航定居迦太基的最初殖民者之一的后代而感到自豪。所以大概，我的意思是，他长得有点像黎巴嫩人，也许有点像年轻时的纳西姆·尼古拉斯·塔勒布。嗯，当我读到这里时，我查了一下，寻找著名的黎巴嫩名人。你知道那个天生就要扮演他的好莱坞明星，他自己就有黎巴嫩血统，文斯·沃恩。
Vince Vaughan? He's not as young as he was, is he? Well, he perhaps just missed the boat. But I think Vince Vaughan playing Hannibal would be a really unexpected. Vin Diesel would be raging at that. He'd be furious. Yeah. Vince Vaughan got in first.
文斯·沃恩？他可不比当年年轻了，对吧？嗯，他大概只是错失良机了。但我认为文斯·沃恩扮演汉尼拔会是一个非常出人意料的选择。范·迪塞尔会对此大发雷霆的。他会气疯的。是的。文斯·沃恩抢先了一步。
Or my friend George Saab, who is Lebanese, and I can't see him doing it either. Okay, but no one knows who he is, Tom. No, I know. I know. Right. Well, so we don't really know what he looked like, but he kind of probably looked vaguely Lebanese. What about his personality?
或者我的朋友乔治·萨布，他是黎巴嫩人，我也看不出他能胜任。好吧，但是没人知道他是谁，汤姆。不，我知道。我知道。好吧，所以我们真的不知道他长什么样，但他大概长得有点像黎巴嫩人。他的性格呢？
Did he have Vin Diesel or Vince Vaughan's personality? Well again, Livy gives a famous description of him and claims that he's a compound of extraordinary qualities and terrible kind of malignant faults. Very much like us. So his qualities, Livy says that he's brave, he's very tough, indefatigable, both physically and mentally he could endure with equal ease extremes of heat or cold. So very like Alexander and indeed you Dominic. He dressed, ate and drank like a common soldier.
他有范·迪塞尔或文斯·沃恩的性格吗？好吧，李维再次对他的外貌进行了著名的描述，并声称他是非凡品质和可怕的恶毒缺陷的混合体。非常像我们。所以关于他的品质，李维说他勇敢、非常坚韧、不知疲倦，无论在身体上还是精神上，他都能以同等轻松的方式忍受极热或极寒的极端天气。所以非常像亚历山大，当然还有你，多米尼克。他的穿衣、饮食和饮水都像普通士兵一样。
He didn't have a special tent, he just rolled himself up in his cloak and no matter how cold it was, very, very smart. So again, like you deep penetrating intelligence. Yeah. And then Dominic, his vices. Yeah, let's get to the vices. So, uh, Libby says he has inhuman cruelty and more than punic perfidy, a total disregard of truth, honor and the gods of the sanctity of an oath and of all
他没有特殊的帐篷，只是把自己卷在斗篷里，不管有多冷，都非常非常聪明。所以再次说明，像你一样具有深刻的洞察力。是的。然后，多米尼克，他的恶习。是的，让我们来谈谈恶习。所以，呃，李维说他具有非同寻常的残忍和超乎寻常的布匿背信弃义，完全无视真理、荣誉、神明、誓言的神圣性以及所有
that other men hold sacred. So again, some canny eerie, very eerie. I mean, I think several things to say about that portrait. Obviously, Livy is a Roman and so he's giving a very Roman perspective. We just don't have any Carthaginian records. Isn't it funny how two of the most celebrated characters in all antiquity, Cleopatra and
其他人视为神圣的事物。所以再次说明，有些地方很诡异，非常诡异。我的意思是，我认为关于那个肖像有几点要说。显然，李维是一个罗马人，所以他提供的是一个非常罗马式的视角。我们只是没有任何迦太基的记录。不觉得很奇怪吗，古代最著名的两个人物，克利奥帕特拉和
Hannibal are basically Roman supervillains. All we know of them comes from the Romans and... Of course, to a degree he's a villain. As with Cleopatra, they both admire and dread this character, right? The Romans are always, and Livy being the exemplar, always emphasize and acknowledge his qualities, which are of course self-evident from his record because Hannibal would prove himself one of the greatest generals of all time. But there's also the fact that the more impressive Hannibal is acknowledged to be,
汉尼拔，基本上都是罗马的大反派。我们对他们的了解都来自于罗马人，而且……当然，在某种程度上他是个反派。就像克利奥帕特拉一样，他们既钦佩又畏惧这个角色，对吧？罗马人总是——而李维就是典范——总是强调和承认他的品质，这些品质从他的战绩中自然是不言而喻的，因为汉尼拔证明了自己是有史以来最伟大的将领之一。但还有一个事实，那就是汉尼拔越是被公认为令人印象深刻，
the more impressive the feat of the Romans in defeating him. And Hannibal, of course, as a military commander is in a slightly elevated position to Cleopatra. For the Romans, it's humiliating to be fighting a woman. Whereas Hannibal is a foe who's kind of equal, you know, he's a worthy adversary. What about the Punic perfidy though? Punic, the word that the Romans used to apply to the Carthaginians, this is a stereotype, their sense that all Carthaginians are treacherous and tricky is absolutely standard. And I think in Hannibal's case, it comes from the fact that he is indeed very cunning, that he has an incredible mastery of stratagems and traps. And essentially what Livy is complaining about is Hannibal's consistent ability to
罗马人击败他的壮举就越显impressive（令人印象深刻）。而且汉尼拔，作为一个军事指挥官，其地位当然比克利奥帕特拉稍微高一些。对罗马人来说，和一个女人打仗是耻辱。而汉尼拔是一个势均力敌的敌人，你知道的，他是一个值得尊敬的对手。不过，布匿式的背信弃义是怎么回事呢？布匿，这个词是罗马人用来称呼迦太基人的，这是一种刻板印象，他们认为所有迦太基人都奸诈狡猾，这是绝对标准的。我想在汉尼拔的案子里，这源于这样一个事实：他确实非常狡猾，他对计谋和陷阱有着令人难以置信的掌控力。而李维真正在抱怨的，本质上是汉尼拔始终如一地
make a succession of Roman commanders look absolute idiots. Right. So you can kind of see where that's coming from. The other accusations that he's an oath breaker that has no respect for the gods. We will see whether that's fair or not in due course. Okay. So what's obviously happening with Hannibal is that his father has taken him to Spain when he was nine and has basically trained him.
让一连串的罗马指挥官显得像绝对的白痴。对吧。所以你可以理解这种说法的来源。其他关于他是破誓者、对神明毫无敬意的指控。我们将在适当的时候看看这是否公正。好吧。所以关于汉尼拔，显然发生的事情是，他的父亲在他九岁时把他带到了西班牙，并基本上训练了他。
Yeah. Ever since then to command a war machine. The end goal being that one day you will take on the Romans. Is it as explicit as that? Well, I already mentioned that the idea of Hamilcar as a lion and his three sons, Hannibal, Hasdrubal and Mago as his cubs. And there's a famous saying that the Romans attribute to Hamilcar that these are the lion cubs I am rearing for the destruction of Rome. I think that's an exaggeration. As we will see, I don't think Hannibal ever aimed to destroy Rome. Destroying your enemies is something that the Romans do. The Carthaginians, I don't think we're
是的。从那时起，为了指挥战争机器。最终目标是有一天你要对抗罗马。事情有那么明确吗？嗯，我之前提到过哈米尔卡是一头狮子，他的三个儿子汉尼拔、哈斯德鲁巴和马戈是他的幼崽。有一个著名的说法，罗马人将之归咎于哈米尔卡，说这些是我为了毁灭罗马而抚养的狮子幼崽。我认为那是夸大其词。正如我们将看到的，我认为汉尼拔从未旨在毁灭罗马。毁灭你的敌人是罗马人做的事。迦太基人，我不认为我们
planning to do that. But indisputably, Hamilcar's ambition in raising his three sons for war is to restore Carthage's status as great power. And if this involves going to war with Rome, as Hamilcar clearly suspects it will, then so be it. It will be the ultimate trial for his dynasty and for his city. And so Hannibal needs to be prepared for that trial. And it has to be said that Hamilcar, you know, prepares his elder son for this great test. Unbelievably well. Right.
计划这样做。但无可争辩的是，哈米尔卡培养三个儿子打仗的雄心，是为了恢复迦太基作为大国的地位。如果这涉及到与罗马开战，正如哈米尔卡清楚地预料到的那样，那也随它去吧。这将是他家族和城市的终极考验。因此汉尼拔需要为这一考验做好准备。必须说的是，哈米尔卡（你知道的）为这一伟大考验培养他的大儿子，做得好得令人难以置信。对吧。
And then when Hasdrubal the handsome succeeded Hannibal, he had Hannibal as his cavalry commander, didn't he? There's no feuding there. You might expect there to be tension between the two of them, but not at all. No. And again, there's a comparison with Alexander who as a young man commands Philip's cavalry by the time that Hannibal becomes supremo in Spain, he has established himself as a very formidable cavalry commander, but more than that, I think it's given him a sense of the importance and the potential of cavalry in expediting a sense of mobility.
然后，当美男子哈斯德鲁巴接替汉尼拔时，他让汉尼拔担任他的骑兵指挥官，不是吗？那里没有不和。你可能会期望他们两个之间会有紧张关系，但完全没有。没有。再次，这与亚历山大进行了比较，亚历山大年轻时指挥腓力的骑兵；当汉尼拔成为西班牙的最高统帅时，他已经把自己确立为一名非常强大的骑兵指挥官，但不仅如此，我认为这赋予了他一种意识，即骑兵在提升机动性方面的重要性和潜力。
And this again is something that he will display throughout his career and probably. You know, it's hard to think of a contemporary cavalry commander who could outclass Hannibal by the time he becomes kind of supremo in 221. And this is again significant for Carthage's prospects in any land war with the Romans, because the Roman cavalry is definitely secondary to their infantry, which are heavy, heavily armored, and therefore potentially ponderous. So there is scope there. You know, there are things that Hannibal can make play with. And again, just to reiterate this comparison with Alexander the Great, he's inherited this war machine. He's got this kind of early training as a cavalry commander. He's obviously personally very, very charismatic when he pointed out that Hasdrubal doesn't in any way seem to have been jealous of him. He clearly admires and respects Hannibal, even though he's younger and his obvious successor.
而这也是他在整个职业生涯中将要展现的特质，可能也是。你知道，很难想象在221年他成为最高统帅时，有哪位当代骑兵指挥官能够超越汉尼拔。这对迦太基在与罗马的任何陆战中的前景再次具有重要意义，因为罗马的骑兵绝对不如他们的步兵重要，罗马步兵是重型的、重装铠甲的，因此可能很笨重。所以这里有发挥的空间。你知道的，汉尼拔可以利用这些来做文章。而且，再次重申与亚历山大大帝的这种比较，他继承了这台战争机器。他接受了这种早期的骑兵指挥官训练。显然他个人非常有魅力，正如人们所指出的，哈斯德鲁巴似乎在任何方面都没有嫉妒他。他显然钦佩并尊重汉尼拔，尽管汉尼拔比他年轻，并且是显而易见的继承人。
He has all these young officers who've grown up around him, one of whom, Mago, his youngest brother, seems to have been particularly close to him. And he even has a Greek tutor, who's a Spartan called Sossilus, who will accompany Hannibal on his campaigns and write up a biography. Again, that's very Alexander, isn't it? Having your own historian. But do you think it's plausible that he was consciously modeling himself from Alexander or is that overstated? Are we projecting that onto him with hindsight?
他身边有许多在他周围长大的年轻军官，其中一个，他的小弟弟马戈，似乎与他特别亲近。他甚至还有一个希腊家庭教师，是一个名叫索西卢斯的斯巴达人，他将陪伴汉尼拔进行战役并写一本传记。这真的很“亚历山大”，不是吗？拥有自己的历史学家。但你认为他是有意识地模仿亚历山大，还是这种说法被夸大了？我们是否在事后诸葛亮地将这一点投射到他身上？
Well, Alexander's influence is manifest to the degree that Alexander is an influence on every general in the century that follows his great course of campaigns. Alexander is an influence on every general in the century that follows his great course of campaigns. But I don't think that Hannibal has anything like Alexander's desire to just push eastwards, ever eastwards. Hannibal's goals are much more succinct, much more circumscribed. He essentially wants to reestablish Carthage as the greatest power in the Western Mediterranean that will obviously require Rome to be Humbled to a degree and so Hannibal is prepared to do that, but he doesn't I think want to obliterate Rome. So if
嗯，亚历山大的影响是显而易见的，在亚历山大伟大战役之后的整整一个世纪里，他是每一位将军的共同影响。亚历山大对随后的一个世纪中的每一位将领都有影响。但我认为汉尼拔根本没有亚历山大那种只想向东推进、永远向东推进的渴望。汉尼拔的目标要简练得多，也局限得多。他基本上想把迦太基重新确立为西地中海最强大的国家，这显然需要罗马在一定程度上受到羞辱，因此汉尼拔准备这样做，但我认为他并不想彻底消灭罗马。所以如果
This means war with Rome Then Hannibal is prepared to go to war with Rome But I think his preference would probably be, I'd rather not have war if we can possibly avoid it. He wants his empire in Spain and if he can develop that empire in Spain without war with Rome, then all the better. But that's where the storm clouds of war begin together, isn't it? In Spain. They do, yeah. The Romans by now have woken up to the fact that Spain is very lucrative and Spain is going to be, as it were, the flashpoint, because they are not going to allow the Carthaginians just to occupy the entire peninsula.
这意味着与罗马开战，那么汉尼拔就准备与罗马开战。但我认为他的首选可能是，如果能避免的话，我宁愿不打仗。他想要他在西班牙的帝国，如果他能在不在与罗马开战的情况下发展那个帝国，那就再好不过了。但战争的乌云正是在那里开始聚集的，不是吗？在西班牙。的确是的，是的。罗马人此时已经意识到西班牙非常赚钱，西班牙将成为所谓的导火索，因为他们绝不会允许迦太基人就这样占领整个半岛。
Yeah, we say that, but actually the first treaty that establishes the relations between Carthage and Rome in Spain, it's brought about by a Roman position of weakness. So in 225, the Romans are facing an invasion of Gauls. So Gaul, what's now France, and the Gauls had already a century or so before invaded Italy and actually captured Rome. So the Romans are very, very anxious about Gauls. They know that they're a menacing enemy. This invasion in 225 causes them great alarm and they're anxious that if the Gauls do invade Italy then this will provide scope for the Carthaginians to start messing around.
是的，我们这么说，但实际上确立西班牙迦太基与罗马关系的第一项条约，是由罗马处于劣势时促成的。所以在225年，罗马人面临着高卢人的入侵。所以高卢，也就是现在的法国，高卢人在大约一个世纪前就已经入侵了意大利并实际上攻占了罗马。因此罗马人对高卢人非常非常焦虑。他们知道这是一个具有威胁性的敌人。225年的这次入侵引起了他们的巨大恐慌，他们担心如果高卢人真的入侵意大利，这将为迦太基人开始胡作非为提供机会。
So they sent an embassy to Hasdrubal who's still alive at this point and they sign a formal treaty and by its terms the Carthaginians pledge not to cross the river Ebro which is a great river that joins the Mediterranean south of where Barcelona is today and then it flows from the northwest in a line parallel to the Pyrenees. And it's agreed that the Romans will accept everywhere south of the Ebro as being Carthaginian and in the North, the Carthaginians will not kind of intrude North of the Ebro. Right.
因此，他们派遣了一个使团去见当时仍然活着的哈斯德鲁巴，他们签署了一项正式条约。根据该条约的条款，迦太基人保证不跨越埃布罗河，这是一条大河，在今天巴塞罗那以南汇入地中海，然后从西北方向流过，与比利牛斯山脉平行。双方商定，罗马人承认埃布罗河以南的所有地方都属于迦太基，而在北部，迦太基人不会侵入埃布罗河以北。对吧。
But having signed this treaty, the Romans then can't help hedging their bets. And so shortly after they've signed this treaty with Hasdrubal, pledging that they won't poke their noses into Carthaginian affairs south of the river Ebro, they annihilate the Gallic invasion, which means that that threat is removed and they start slightly regretting this treaty that they've signed. And so it's around the same time, and surely not coincidentally, that they establish friendly relations with an Iberian town called Saguntum, which lies on the coast, so very good communications with Rome by the sea, and the Saguntines become the kind of the Romans' eyes in Spain, kind
但在签署了这项条约之后，罗马人又忍不住留有后路。因此，就在他们与哈斯德鲁巴签署了保证不插手埃布罗河以南迦太基事务的条约后不久，他们消灭了高卢人的入侵，这意味着威胁被解除了，他们开始对签署的这项条约感到略微后悔。因此，大约在同一时期，而且肯定不是巧合的是，他们与一个名叫萨古通姆的伊比利亚城镇建立了友好关系，该城镇位于海岸线上，因此与罗马的海上交通非常便利，萨古通姆人成为了罗马人在西班牙的眼睛，有点像
of sending the Romans intelligence updates on what the Carthaginians are up to. And they are qualified to do this because they lie just beyond the reach of Carthaginians are up to. And they are qualified to do this because they lie just beyond the reach of Carthaginian control. However, there is no guarantee that this will be permanently the case because Surguntum lies five miles south of the Ebro. Which means that according to the treaty that the Romans have signed with the Carthaginians. Yeah. They are within the Carthaginian sphere of influence. I was about to say, when you look at a map, it's now Sagunto, which is not far from Valencia in the south of Spain.
向罗马人发送关于迦太基人行动的情报更新。他们之所以有资格这样做，是因为他们恰好位于迦太基控制范围之外的边缘。然而，这并不能保证永远如此，因为苏尔贡图姆位于埃布罗河以南五英里处。这意味着，根据罗马人与迦太基人签署的条约。是的。他们处于迦太基的影响范围之内。我正要说的是，当你查看地图时，它现在是萨贡托，离西班牙南部的瓦伦西亚不远。
It clearly is a massive infringement of the treaty. It absolutely is. And it's absolutely kind of classic. This is traditional Roman mischief making. There is massive scope for a bust up. However, the crisis does take time to brew because to begin with Hannibal's focus is not on Surguntum. What he wants to do is secure Carthaginian control deep into central Spain along the line of the river Tagus, this river that flows through the centre of the
这显然是对条约的大规模侵犯。绝对是。而且这绝对是一种经典的、传统的罗马式恶作剧。这里有巨大的爆发冲突的空间。然而，危机确实需要时间酝酿，因为一开始汉尼拔的注意力不在苏尔贡图姆。他要做的是沿着塔古斯河的路线，将迦太基的控制权深入到西班牙中部，这条河流流经半岛的中心。
peninsula. And he's essentially following Hasdrubal the Handsome's policy. So he too takes a Spanish wife, you know, he wants to make sure of the loyalty of the Iberians as well as of the Carthaginians. Again, he's very happy to take the fight to those Iberians who oppose him. He fights two brilliant campaigns in 222-221. He wins his first major pitched battle. It's against enemies who massively outnumber him. He wipes them out by drawing them in. He tricks them, divides them up, surrounds them, wipes them out with elephants. So again, there's lots of kind of pointers there to the kind of military courses he'll
他基本上是在遵循哈斯德鲁巴·美男子的政策。所以他也娶了一个西班牙妻子，你知道的，他想确保伊比利亚人以及迦太基人的忠诚。同样，他非常乐意向那些反对他的伊比利亚人发起战斗。他在222-221年打了两场精彩的战役。他赢得了他的第一场重大阵地战。对手在人数上大大超过了他。他通过诱敌深入将他们消灭。他欺骗他们、分化他们、包围他们，用大象将他们消灭。所以，这里有很多迹象表明他将采取的军事方针。
be adopting. He storms towns, he takes loot, he rewards his troops very, very lavishly. And it becomes apparent that his men really adore him because he gives them victory, he makes them rich, and it's evident that he cares for them kind of very, very deeply. So the more campaigns Hannibal conducts, the more he can be confident that his war machine is really primed and ready to go. And now that he's got almost the whole of central Spain conquered, his eye turns to the last stretch south of the Ebro,
他攻城拔寨，夺取战利品，非常慷慨地奖赏他的军队。显而易见，他的士兵非常崇拜他，因为他带给他们胜利，使他们变得富有，并且很明显他非常非常深刻地关心他们。因此，汉尼拔进行的战役越多，他就越能确信他的战争机器已经真正准备就绪。现在他几乎征服了整个西班牙中部，他的目光转向了埃布罗河以南的最后一段，
by which according to a treaty with Rome, he's entitled to conquer. And that's the coastal stretch, which of course includes Ser Guntum. And so in the year 220, at the end of the campaigning season, he returns to new Carthage. Everybody knows that Surguntum is ready for the following year and he finds a Roman embassy waiting for him.
根据与罗马的条约，他有权征服那里。那就是沿海地区，当然包括塞尔贡图姆。因此，在公元前220年，在作战季结束时，他回到了新迦太基。每个人都知道苏尔贡图姆为第二年做好了准备，他发现有一支罗马使团在等着他。
Greggy. And so do they give him what? A settlement? An ultimatum? What have they got in their locker? They issue him a form of caution and to quote Livy that he should leave the people of Saguntum in peace as allies of the Roman people and Hannibal treats this with absolute scorn. I mean he clearly finds the tone of the ambassadors very offensive.
格雷吉。那么他们给了他什么？一个解决方案？最后通牒？他们有什么筹码？他们向他发出了一种警告，引用李维的话说，他应该让萨贡图姆人民安居乐业，作为罗马人民的盟友，而汉尼拔对此表现得极其轻蔑。我的意思是，他显然觉得大使们的语气非常具有攻击性。
You know Carthage and Rome have this treaty. He can do what he likes to Saguntum by the terms of that treaty. And I think more than that it would have reminded him of how the Romans have played this trick before, because essentially the war in Sicily. That kicked off the first Punic war. So the first great conflict between Roman Carthage, the Romans have pulled exactly the same stunt. They had invaded Sicily with the defense that they were defending
你知道迦太基和罗马有这个条约。根据该条约的条款，他对萨贡图姆想做什么都可以。而且我认为更重要的是，这会让他想起罗马人以前是怎么玩这个把戏的，因为本质上是西西里的战争。这引发了第一次布匿战争。因此，在罗马和迦太基之间的第一场大战中，罗马人完全演出了同样的把戏。他们入侵西西里，借口是他们在保卫他们在西西里招募的朋友。是的。这显然导致罗马人征服了整个岛屿。汉尼拔知道罗马人在这一套上很有经验。他决心不让罗马人在西班牙立足，并不试图在那里玩同样的把戏。所以他以其人之道还治其人之身。他说，你知道的，他在苏尔贡图姆有朋友，他们正受到罗马人的敌对派系的威胁。所以基本上这是他的道义责任
friends that they'd recruited in Sicily. Yeah. And that had obviously ended up with the Romans conquering the whole island. And Hannibal knows the Romans have form here. He's determined not to allow the Romans to get a foothold in Spain and to try and play the same trick there. So he plays the Romans at their own game. And he says that he, you know, he has friends in Surguntum and they're being menaced by hostile faction by the Romans. So basically it's his moral duty
去攻击并攻占萨贡图姆。我的意思是，他显然对罗马的外交以及军事技术进行了非常仔细的研究。他正在做罗马人做的事情。所以我们处于公元前220年。你可以非常清楚地看到公元前219、218、217年这如何可能导致战争，对吧？就在那里，存在着这个冲突点和不可调和的立场，是的，因为我认为很明显，在公元前219年，汉尼拔完全铁了心要攻击苏尔贡图姆，但他其实不必这么做，对吧？所以即使在当时，也有古代历史学家、古代作家认为他本可以做出不同的选择，那么
to attack and, and capture Saguntum. I mean, he's clearly studied Roman diplomacy as well as military techniques very closely. And he's doing exactly what the Romans do. So we're in two 20. So you can see very clearly how two 19 to 18 to 17. This might lead to war, right? right there's this flashpoint in the irreconcilable positions yeah because I think it's clear that in 219 Hannibal is absolutely set on attacking Surguntham but he didn't have to right so there were even at the time there were ancient historians ancient authors who thought he could have made a different choice and then
历史将会完全朝着不同的方向展开。是的。所以在战争结束后，也就是汉尼拔的战争，有人说他本可以要求罗马人归还萨丁尼亚，例如，并免除强加给他们的非法赔偿金。他们会同意吗？这看起来太不像罗马人了，他们怎么会这么做呢。没错。这显然就是为什么汉尼拔从未想过采取这种政策，因为这根本不可能发生。
history would have unfold folded completely differently. Yeah. So it was said in the wake of the war, Hannibal's war, that he could have asked the Romans to hand back Sardinia, for instance, and to remit the indemnity that had been illegally imposed on them. Were they ever going to do that? That seems so un-Roman, seems so unlikely that they would ever have done that. Right. That's obviously why Hannibal never even thought to adopt that policy because it was never going to happen.
没错。罗马人绝不会同意支付或交出萨丁尼亚，因为这不是罗马人的行事风格。无论如何，汉尼拔可能在想，不，假设我真的进攻并占领了苏尔贡图姆，你知道，罗马人能对此做些什么呢？罗马距离西班牙很远。是的。他们真的会为了这一个城市而冒战争的风险吗？
Right. And the Romans would never have agreed to pay to surrender Sardinia because that's not what the Romans do. And anyway, Hannibal is probably thinking, no, suppose I do attack in an exeguntum, you know, what are the Romans going to do about it? Rome is a long way from Spain. Yeah. Are they really going to risk war over this one city?
即使他们真的这么做，放马过来吧。你知道，我有这支令人惊叹的军队。我已经准备好了。很明显，并非只有汉尼拔一个人这么想。迦太基的元老院也这么想，因为曾去见汉尼拔的罗马使团随后去了迦太基，抗议汉尼拔的行为。那里的元老院，尽管他们中的许多人并不特别喜欢汉尼拔，而且对他有点嫉妒，但他们基本上说，你知道的，
And even if they do, bring it on. You know, I've got this amazing army. I'm ready to go. It's clear that Hannibal is not alone in thinking this. The Senate back in Carthage think this too, because the Roman embassy that had been to see Hannibal then go to Carthage to complain about Hannibal's behavior. And the Senate there, even though lots of them don't particularly like Hannibal and they're kind of jealous of him, they basically say, you know,
滚开。我们不接受这个，你知道的。因此，基本上迦太基形成了一个统一战线。这意味着在公元前219年初，汉尼拔开始了对苏尔贡图姆的围城战，他知道自己得到了家乡所有人的全力支持。然而起初——我的意思是，你一直在吹捧汉尼拔和他的战争机器，但起初萨贡图姆的围城战对他来说并不算太顺利。
piss off. We're not having this, you know. So essentially there is a Carthaginian united front. And this means that in the early summer of 219, Hannibal embarks on the siege of Surguntum knowing that he has the full backing of everyone in his native city. And yet at first, I mean you've been talking up Hannibal and his war machine, but at first that siege of Saguntum doesn't go terribly well for him. No, it's a disaster actually. He gets wounded in the thigh which isn't very helpful and I think in general Hannibal is better in the field than he is kind
不，实际上是一场灾难。他的大腿受了伤，这可没什么帮助，而且我认为总体而言，汉尼拔在战场上的表现比他……攻城略地要好。所以整个夏天，整个秋天，直到冬天，萨贡图姆仍然没有陷落，如果罗马人进行干预，那么这可能对汉尼拔来说是个真正的问题。但罗马人没有干预。其原因本质上有点像三十年代的英国。你知道，存在着巨大的分歧。有一派所谓的战争党，他们说，你知道，我们必须这么做，否则就会导致灾难。还有其他人说，哦，我对这一点不太确定。因此，罗马内部的这些分歧使汉尼拔得以继续围城，直到
of laying siege to cities. So all through the summer, all through the autumn, into the winter, Saguntum still hasn't fallen and had the Romans intervened, then it could potentially have been a real problem for Hannibal. But the Romans don't intervene. And the reason for that is essentially, it's a bit like Britain in the 30s. You know, there's massive disagreement. There's a kind of war party and they're saying, you know, we've got to do this or else, you know, it's going to lead to disaster. And there are others who say, oh, I'm not sure about that. And so these disagreements in Rome enable Hannibal to prosecute the siege until in
公元前218年初，这座城市终于陷落了。这座城市被洗劫一空，人口要么被屠杀，要么被卖为奴隶。这对汉尼拔来说是一个绝对的胜利。回到罗马，这个消息引起了强烈的愤怒，但我也认为，还有耻辱感。从这一点开始，罗马人将永远不会停止将苏尔贡图姆的陷落描述为一场可怕的战争罪行，而他们自己是绝不会犯下这种罪行的。我的意思是，这看起来像是一件如此标准的行为，但也正是罗马人一直在做的那种事。
early 218, the city finally falls. The city is stripped of all its treasure, the population are either slaughtered or sold into slavery. It's an absolute triumph for Hannibal. And back in Rome, the news of this prompts intense feelings of anger, but also, I think, of shame. And from this point on, the Romans will never cease to characterize the capture of Surguntum as a terrible war crime of the kind that they themselves would never commit. I mean, this, it seems like such a standard thing, but also the kind of thing the Romans did all the time.
绝对是的。因此，罗马人在其中的虚伪，我认为相当了不起。而且我认为罗马元老院内部仍然有一些人意识到了这一点。因此，仍然存在着一个派别，虽然算不上真正的和平党，但它是一个说：“哦，我们真的确信我们想为此开战吗？”的派别。是的。这个派别由一个非常杰出的元老院人物领导，名叫昆图斯·法比乌斯·马克西姆·巴鲁科苏斯。也就是疣面人，有点像克伦威尔，他的鼻子上有个疣。没错。他说，听着，在我们宣战之前，让我们再次发出和平试探。让我们向迦太基派遣使团。
Absolutely is. So the hypocrisy of the Romans in this, I think is quite something. And I think that there are still elements within the Roman Senate who recognize this. So there is a still, it's not exactly a peace party, but it's a faction that says, Oh, are we really sure we want to go to war over this? Yeah. And this faction is led by a very distinguished senatorial figure called Quintus Fabius Maximus Baruchosus. So warty, a bit like a Cromwell, he's got a wart on his nose. Right. And he says, look, before we declare war, let's put out the peace feelers again. Let's send an embassy to Carthage.
你知道，看看我们是否能向汉尼拔在迦太基的敌人进行试探，并试图避免公开战争。我认为这部分是因为，你知道，他们认为这场战争可能会相当困难，但也因为罗马人本质上是一个非常重道德的民族，他们不想承担挑起战争的罪责。他们正试图将任何冲突的责任完全归咎于迦太基人。因此，罗马使团前往迦太基并抵达那里，尽管有这种“让我们去与迦太基人谈判”的姿态，但他们是罗马人，他们并不是真正去谈判的。他们的初始要求是如此
You know, let's see if we can open feelers to Hannibal's enemies in Carthage and just try and avoid open war. And I think this is partly because, you know, they think the war might be quite difficult, but also because genuinely the Romans are a very kind of moralistic people and they don't want the guilt of starting the war. They're trying to absolutely pin the blame for any conflict on the Carthaginians. So the Roman embassy goes to Carthage and they arrive there, but despite this kind of, you know, let's go negotiate with the Carthaginians, they're Romans, they're not really there to negotiate. And their starting demand is so
显而易见的不可能，以至于他们实际上是在白费口舌。初始要求是应该将汉尼拔交还给罗马人。迦太基人绝不可能这样做。即使是汉尼拔最死硬的敌人也认识到，如果他们交出这位掌管迦太基西班牙的负责人，那将是西班牙的末日。你知道，罗马人会毫不犹豫地搬进来。是的，当然。因此，谈判毫无进展，首席罗马大使——可能是昆图斯·法比乌斯·马克西姆，也可能是他的堂弟，史料记载互相矛盾——站了起来，这是一个非常著名的场景，我将引用一个罗马
obviously impossible that effectively they're wasting their breath. And the starting demand is that Hannibal should be surrendered to the Romans. And there's no way that the Carthaginians are going to do this. Even Hannibal's bitterest enemies can recognize that if they hand over the guy who's in charge of Carthaginian Spain, that will be the end of Spain. You know, the Romans will move in, no question. Yeah, of course. And so negotiations go nowhere and the leading Roman ambassador who may be Quintus Fabius Maximus or perhaps his cousin, the sources are contradictory, he stands up, a very famous scene and I'll quote a Roman
描述它的史料。他指着自己托加袍的胸部，向迦太基元老院宣称，在他的衣褶里既装着和平也装着战争，他会把他们指示他留下哪一个就从里面放出来。迦太基最高行政长官回答说，他应该拿出他认为最好的一件，当特使回答说将是战争时，许多元老，也就是那些迦太基人，立刻大喊：我们接受。正是在这些条款下，元老院和罗马大使分道扬镳。所以战争的乌云不仅已经聚拢，汤姆。风暴正在进行中。
source that describes it. He pointed to the bosom of his toga and declared to the Carthaginian Senate that in its folds he carried both peace and war and that he would let fall from it whichever they instructed him to leave. The Carthaginian chief magistrate answered that he should bring out whichever he thought best and when the envoy replied that it would be war, many of the senators, so those of the Carthaginians, shouted at once, we accept it. It was on these terms that the Senate and the Roman ambassadors parted. So the storm clouds of war have not merely gathered, Tom. The storm is underway. Yeah, as Chris Morris would say, it's war. It is war and
是的，正如克里斯·莫里斯所说，这就是战争。这就是战争，而且这个故事里还有那么多内容，有大象，有翻越阿尔卑斯山，有激烈的战役，特雷比亚战役，特拉西梅诺湖战役，最后在这场宏伟系列的末尾，是古代历史上最伟大的战役之一，甚至可以说是整个历史上，坎尼战役。所以，汤姆，如果人们想立刻听到所有这些故事，他们可以做些什么呢？好吧，多米尼克，通过一项令人惊叹的创新，我们建立了一个私人俱乐部，使你可以访问所有四个剧集。而且非常简单。
there's so much to come in this story there's elephants there's crossing the Alps there's tremendous battles the Battle of Trebia the Battle of Lake Trasimene and finally at the end of this mighty series one of the great battles in all ancient history indeed in history full stop the Battle of Cannae so Tom what can people do if they want to hear all this story right away? Well, Dominic, in a stunning innovation, we've set up a private club, which enables you to access all four episodes. And it's very simple.
你访问“the rest is history.com”，价格非常非常合理。不是吗？多米尼克，这简直就像是白送一样。所以这就是你可以做的。你可以在那里获得所有四集。听着，这些剧集将是我们在《历史的其余部分》中所做过的最史诗般、最惊险刺激、最血腥、最迷人的剧集。千万不要错过。汤姆，非常感谢你，我们下次再见。拜拜。拜拜。大家好，你们还在。就在剧集的最后，我对你们的执着印象深刻。
You go to the rest is history.com and very, very reasonably priced. Isn't it? Dominic very, very giving it away. So that's what you can do. and you can get all four episodes there. And listen, these episodes will be some of the most epic, the most swashbuckling and the most bloody and the most glamorous that we've ever done in the rest of history. Do not miss it. Tom, thank you so much for that and we will see you next time. Bye bye. Bye bye. Hi everybody, you're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed
但听着，我有个问题要问你们。我想秘密地问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些剧集里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗？我希望这个播客的听众，我希望他们听的是关于我品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你这么想过，那么当然只有一种方法可以知道那会是什么样子。你可以打断广告的进程。你可以成为下一个汇丰银行卓越理财（HSBC Premier）或曾在《历史的其余部分》上做过广告的许多其他了不起的公司之一。
by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what? I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that there is of course, only one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest of history.
你可以通过在《历史的其余部分》以及目标挂钩网络（Goalhanger Network）的其他节目上做广告，将你的品牌展示在数百万志同道合的听众面前。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是目标挂钩网络。Goalhanger 是制作这个节目的公司。如果你正打算提升你品牌的价值，Goalhanger 将非常乐意听到你的声音。你可以立即访问 goalhanger.com 注册你的兴趣或者你公司的兴趣，那是 goal，G-O-A-L，hanger，H-A-N-G-E-R 点 com 这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
And you could put your brand in front of millions of like-minded listeners by advertising on the rest of history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is. Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest or indeed your company's interest by going to goalhanger.com right now and that is goal, G-O-A-L, hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R dot com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以通过在《The Rest of History》以及Goalhanger网络旗下的其他节目上投放广告，将您的品牌展示给数百万志同道合的听众。现在您可能会想，我不知道什么是Goalhanger网络。Goalhanger正是制作这档节目的公司。如果您正打算提升品牌的价值，Goalhanger非常期待您的垂询。您现在就可以访问 goalhanger.com 注册您或您公司的意向，网址是 goal，拼写是 G-O-A-L，hangar，拼写是 H-A-N-G-E-R，点 com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。